pertes la semaine qui s'ouvre sera
marquée demain au plan judiciaire par la
reprise du procès de patrick dils avec
la confrontation très attendue de
francis heaulme tueur en série à la fois
témoin et suspect dans cette affaire
retour sur les premiers jours d'audience
où la déposition des enquêteurs aura été
le premier tournante de ce procès à huis
clos
valérie a réitéré mon chapeau car le
face à face très attendu va pouvoir
commencer
l'ex inspecteur varley qui a mené toute
l'enquète est appelé à témoigner
l'enquêteur a toujours cru patrick dils
coupable depuis des années l'accusé
clame son innocence durant plusieurs
heures
l'ancien policier a expliqué à la cour
son enquête qui quinze ans plus tôt l'a
amené à confondre patrick dils mais le
temps passe et a aussi changé l'accusé
face à l'inspecteur pour la première
fois patrick dils eux se lève et
proteste expliquant comment selon lui la
police la subtile m'ont amené à passer
des aveux des pressions psychologiques
mais surtout un scénario du crime qui
lui aurait été suggéré et qu'il n'aurait
fait que répéter un prince à face et une
déposition dans tes peurs très
diversement ressentie par les deux
parties les dépositions qui viennent
faire sont très complètes alors il est
normal que le président s'interroge sur
d'éventuelles pressions sur la
suggestibilité
le patrick dils et cetera mais à ceux à
ces questions là je suis parler semble
répondre d'une manière tout à fait
claire
on lui semblait dire ce que patrick
avait été un peu mise à mal j'ai pas
trouvé le contraire que par patrick là
c'est vraiment bien exprimé hier
oui
à mon avis plutôt pas mal les audiences
sont interminables
il est plus d'une heure du matin à
l'intérieur le policier puis la juge
d'instruction nie toujours toute
pression sur patrick dils qui aura été
le plus convaincant devant la cour le
huis clos qui interdit aux journalistes
d'être présent empêche définitivement
d'apporter une réponse demain ce sera
l'autre tournant de ce procès que tueur
en série francis heaulme va devoir
expliquer ce qu'il faisait tout près du
lieu du crime
le jour du double meurtre